[Music]
feeling like a failure or life passed
you by
I can't take any more rejection honey
you remember Kevin Wow kit you look just
the same so what's your plan now that
you've been kicked out of school
I've taken a temporary position and a
public relations firm did you always
know this is what you wanted to do or
did you want to do another thing first
like did I dream of figure skating but
my parents wouldn't pay for the lessons
you don't want to be a temp forever do
you get got a letter for you get ready
get ready for what
[Music]
you have come to the store kit and I am
the salesman behold we sell what you
need unicorns
there was the only thing I ever wanted
if I have one brought here I have to
know that you are for real I've made a
decision
I'm building a home worthy of you
unicorn is thinking something like a
stable I don't think a pony wants to
live in your basement it's a good point
do you think this is some kind of joke
should we just get you a puppy I know
that I'm just a disappointment or always
like why don't you have a boyfriend why
are you just more like Kevin someone
call me no don't know how to be a grown
up my parents think that I'm insane
honey what was really going on this is
crazy the most grown-up thing you can do
is fail at things you really care about
you need to learn to love you soon get
out there and show us what you can do
you got that
everybody needs a magic in their lives
even if they're all grown up
tell me where does this unicorn come
from - unicorn star oh of course
[Music]
[Music]